- So, I'm gonna start with this
'cause it seems like a crazy number.
25 million Instagram followers.
Is there pressure in that?
Do you feel like you have
to post at that point?
- Yeah, I definitely do feel that,
but I also give myself
the liberty to just like,
not care that much.
- Good.
- I feel like I'm constantly like,
I probably shouldn't say this.
- It's like a whole separate job.
- I'm like, I like
continuously lose followers
every time I post.
So I feel like I'm like,
"All right, bye, I guess."
So, I'm like, maybe it's better
if I just don't remind them
that they're following me, and then.
- Just under the radar.
- Yeah.
- You're turning 30 soon.
Are you excited about this?
- I'm really excited to turn 30.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm like...
- [Kelly] Thirties are fun.
- That's what I hear.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I just feel like your
thirties, especially as a woman,
it's really when you come into yourself
and you stop caring about
what other people think.
- Yeah.
- I feel like that's
already coming for me.
And you know, with "Riverdale"
ending after seven years,
I'm like, this feels
like a really great time
to be turning 30.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's like a new chapter.
- I'm excited for you, I
love my thirties, that's fun.
How do you celebrate?
You go big or do you chill?
- I like to have, I'm very social.
I like to have everyone
gather for my birthday.
I really wanna have a bounce
house birthday for my thirties.
(audience cheering)
- I love you.
I love that.
- I wanna just get a big bounce
house and invite everyone
and have a themed,
like a kid's themed birthday,
maybe like, you know.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Some Disney character
as my cake or something.
- Have a petting zoo.
- [Camila] Yeah, exactly.
- I will tell you, during
COVID, it saved us.
I ordered on, thank you, Amazon.
I ordered a bounce house
'cause my kids were going nuts
and like we were just doing homeschooling
and all that stuff with COVID.
- [Camila] So, you're like
get these guys a bounce house.
- The bounce house saved us.
So I applaud a bounce house move
- You were just on the
bounce house every day.
- Yeah, go get that energy out.
- It was for you, Kelly,
admit it.
- Get out of the house, yeah.